so now that we understand tasks what
comes next
well then you actually start to get
drawing the screens you get to pick up
the pan or the whiteboard marker or the
mouse and start trying to imagine what
these scenes these environments the user
is going to interact with actually look
like so you're going back to the tests
and kind of figuring out what are the
pieces of information that they need to
see what are the pieces of information
they need to provide
how do those will all fit together on
the screen to support that task and from
there you can kind of start building one
screen and maybe a couple of screens
that cover that task and then look for
kind of connections you can start
looking for things that happen earlier
to the user that brought them to this
stage
well those screens want to be related in
some way or you think about things that
they want to do from that point you know
once they complete that task well where
do they go and as you start to kind of
get all these screens you start to build
these flows and connect them you have a
sense of which things are really
important which things are less
important or frequently used you start
to build out the structure for this
experience and you think about okay the
user might come in this way and spend a
lot of time here I'm gonna hop over into
this different condition and spending
time there that starts to guide you
about how the overall navigation of that
experience is going to work and which
tool do you love to use do that oh I
love paper and pencil you know but at
some point you get more and more
detailed with what you're doing so you
can start very coarse you can start with
a whiteboard or scraps of paper because
you want to you want to kind of fail
quickly you want to draw out things
realize what's wrong with them crumple
them up and throw them away and draw
them again a lot of what I do as a
designer is iteration and there's a
saying that writing is rewriting that
applies to design as well design is
redesigning so you designer if you show
it to someone you get some feedback and
then you redesign it yeah absolutely and
you often will draw a lot of different
things and just kind of get a feel for
from feedback and from your own
experience and from the understanding of
the user that you've built up through
all those other steps you know which
ones are the best bets which make the
most sense
and some of that is about kind of making
a choice based on the whole product you
know it's good if you can get to a
smaller number of patterns that the user
has to learn rather than use reading to
learn a hundred different styles of
working with your app right so when do I
know that I'm done with all these tricks
okay so you're never done well that's a
joke
that's unfortunate ma'am sorry okay I
mean it's great you could try but you're
never gonna quite get there like there's
always gonna be something that you you
you want to change you learn something
else from the testing or from putting it
out or there's some new capability that
comes around that you want to
incorporate into this product
you'll get closer and closer you know
you'll continue to approach it you'll
never quite land there so you'll kind of
go through and you'll iterate and you'll
redesign and you'll go to higher and
higher levels of fidelity you'll go from
those pencil sketches to mock-ups to
very polished mock-ups to prototypes
you'll start building it at some point
so that said there's things you can look
for okay you don't have to give up all
that okay so if you you have you covered
all of those tasks that you want to
address like have you completely solved
the problem you were looking at does the
product have a point of view about what
things are important and which aren't
you know if you have the tests that are
high priority like make them feel like
they're important to the user like
stress them so that they know this is
what this product is about you've done
user testing right of course okay so
have you covered all the issues that
arose from that and we can address those
high-priority items and then finally
have you solved the problem you set out
to solve you go back to those original
goals and see am I actually meeting what
I understand I need to do for that user
and what would be a good mark or a
signal to tell me that I need to move
from design to actually do rapid
prototyping or stuff like that you
should do that as rapidly as you can you
know even if you're just doing you know
testing things on paper prototyping it
out using kind of the simplest tools
that you can do you you have that
analysis phase and then once you
to design you know design and
prototyping should be very much
hand-in-hand right um you're the closer
you get to something that feels like a
real experience to a user the better
feedback you're going to get from them
in many cases so you want to get to that
point as rapidly as you can